Avez-vous déjà eu un voisin très bizarre ?
Qui parle tout seul , qui crie ou qui a l'air suspect ?
Eh bien aujourd'hui ça va être le cas !
Qui rentre tard le soir
Qui fait toujours la gueule
Qui fait du bruit le matin
Qui est tout le temps anxieux
Que t'oses pas aller voir parce que t'as peur qu'il te bute
Brref le voisin chelou !
Aujourd'hui on est sur "Hello Neighbor"
Nous sommes dans une petite maison , c'est le soir
Et c'est ce voisin d'en face, le mec chelou
On le suspecte de faire un truc bizarre dans son sous-sol
Cache-t-il des prisonniers ?
Fait-il pousser de la beuh ?
Nous le serons bien ass...
agressé par des sauterelles
OK nous voici donc devant chez lui
la difficulté du jeu
C'est que le mec s'adapte à ta manière de jouer
Heu moi je propose juste de regarder à travers
Au premier abord
Je repère un petit peu
"EXIT" là, il y a une sortie ok
Je vais aller voir derrière s'il y a pas quelque chose
Là il y a une porte derrière
On peut ouvrir ?
Non c'est verrouillé, c'est verrouillé.
Alors comment on peut faire pour rentrer dans cette putain de maison ?
C'est chaud, non ?
Bon écoutez, je propose qu'on fasse la méthode gentille, genre on va toquer
OK
Je suis dedans là ?
Je suis pas déjà ded...
C'est quoi cette maison bizarre ?
C'est l'entrée et elle est grande ouverte
C'est quand même bizarre
C'est quoi ça ?
Des caméras ?
What the fuck mec ?
Rien
Et là-haut regardez comme c'est encombré !
Le gars, il délire totalement !
C'est sûr il est chelou !
EXIT
D'accord, il m'a niqué
Et maintenant il fait jour.
OK !
Alors, mon pote ...
Il regarde la télé, il est là
Il a bien une gueule de mec chelou
Ok, j'ai sonné
et on va se barrer, on va trouver une autre entrée, mec
C'est super malin ce qu'on fait ...
Ok on peut prendre des objets avec "F"
J'ai pris une tomate, mec ...
Il est revenu devant la télé ? Il s'est calmé ?
Ouais, il s'est calmé.
Je peux lancer ça là ?
Merde
Et non elle a disparu !
Attends, on va analyser la trajectoire, on va analyser la trajectoire ...
On fait les choses bien !
Il est là,
Faut que je pète cette pièce
OK, il va aller voir là bas
Comme ça on peut rentrer
WHAT ?
Mais le mec il est fou !
Le frigo ! Le frigo !
Je suis caché !
Oh, il y a des tomates, pourquoi il y a des tomates ?
Je peux prendre une tomate dans mon inventaire pour lui lancer.
Ok c'est le moment ...
Je suis bloq...
Put***
La porte de dehors est ouverte
Je peux me barrer par là, c'est cool
Ah, par contre là je suis bloqué en f...
Non..
Il a un gun ?!  Non, j'ai rêvé.
Je suis prêt à lancer une tomate mon pote, fais gaffe à ce que tu fais ...
Il va revenir par là et moi je vais repasser par l'autre coté
OK, OK, OK..
Alors il faudrait juste qu'on trouve un début, une piste, par où aller.
Ah put*** maintenant c'est la nuit qui va commencer à tomber..
Mec tranquille tranquille, là on est dans la rue tu fais rien du tout !
Moi je te lance une tomate dans ta gue*** sale bât**d
Ok, ok ...
Attends, le mec je m'en fous je veux savoir ce qu'il y a dans son sous sol
J'm'en bats les cou****, frère
Aïe.. c'est quoi ça ? C'est un piège à loup  ? Mais MEC !
Mais mec, t'es fou ...  Pourquoi tu mets des pièges à loup dans ton jardin ?! Mais espèce de fils de ..
'Tain fils de p*** je vais t'e***** je vais t'e****** j't'en**** !
Ok, je prends la bouteille...
Ah ok, en fait, plus on essaie, plus il mets des pièges, des caméras et tout !
D'accord !
Il s'adapte vraiment à ce qu'on fait en fait le gars !
Il a mis un un digicode et tout ? Non mais le gars...
Non mec, j'suis dans la rue, j'suis dans la rue !
Aaah ! J'vais chez moi je vais chez moi je vais chez moi !
Agression là ! Tu m'agresse là ..
WHAT THE FUCK ! Il me lance des tomates !
Eh mec, tu veux te battre ? Qu'est ce qu'il y a maintenant ?
Il me lance un piège a loup non mais ... Allô la police ?! Oui, intrusion chez moi !
Ok, c'est parti !
Put***,  faut pas lui laisser le temps de s'adapter,
sinon il nous met dix mille pièges à ours et tout et ça devient la merde ...
Alors! Donc, il n'a pas encore mit de pièges à ours et pas de cameras
Il est toujours devant, il a rien vu le con.
Donc, on va rentrer ...
Ah ok, yes ! On a réussi à pénétrer dans une nouvelle pièce,
d'accord !
C'est quoi, c'est l'garage ?
Bon il y a rien d'anormal , il y a rien d'anormal
Bon le garage c'est une pièce inutile, du coup ...
Ok ... Suivant !
Oh put***, c'est quoi ça ?
ça c'est une autre pièce inutile avec
plein d'ampoules, je suis sûr que les ampoules vont nous servirent.
On va en prendre une.
On va arriver dans une pièce où on sera dans le noir
et il nous faudra une ampoule, c'est sûr ...
Ok , wouah fils de pu**, putain ...
A priori, il nous a pas encore vu... C'est une chance !
Il faut qu'on aille là, à gauche, sans qu'il nous voit.
Oh fils de pu**
Ok
Une sorte de fournaise et rien d'autre ...
Un balais ? Qu'est ce que tu veux que je foute avec un balais ?
je m'en bat les c***lles
je m'en "balais" c***lles, excellent !
Non.
Le problème, c'est qu'il y a un code sur la porte "Exit" là
Oh ...
Il y a une clé là
Oh mon dieu !
Il faut que j'y aille sans me faire griller, attends
Il faudrait que je l'attire de l'autre coté de la maison.
En fait, si je l'attire là bas, attends ...
Oh merde, non, c'est bon !
aaaaaaaaaah!
Oh je ne vois rien dans le noir, c'est chaud !
Ok les amis, j'ai redémarré le jeu
et d'après euuh... ce qu'on peut voir et de ce que j'ai lu ...
En gros, il y a 4 éléments à choper pour pouvoir ouvrir cette porte là
Bon là, elle est entre ouverte et je crois que la première nuit,
de toute façon, t'es obligé de perdre.
Dans tout les cas, on y va
On va ouvrir
et il apparaît comme par magie et il nous bute.
A partir de là, le vrai jeu commence
et vous voyez il a barricadé la porte, ce petit fdp
Voilà du coup, il faut :
un marteau pour péter la planche,
trouver le code
et la clé qui est ici, bon, elle est sous les yeux
pour déverrouiller le cadenas.
Et ça je peux vous dire que c'est chaud !
Un marteau, logiquement, à part un garage ou un grenier,
je ne vois pas où ça peut être un p**ain de marteau.
Attends, une lampe torche ça peut être très utile par contre ...
Non ça, c'est beaucoup moins utile.
Ok nice !
On a une lampe torche, c'est bien.
Ici, il y a quoi ?
il y a ... *bruit*
Put***
Il faut qu'on se barre ...
Bah, je suis piégé mille ans ! Fils de pu** ! ***crise d'épilepsie **
MERDE !!
Bon c'est raté ! C'est pas grave, on va y retourner.
Je vous jure qu'on va y arriver,  je m'en bat les c***lles,
là, j'ai toute ma journée.
Je ne finirai pas cette vidéo tant qu'on a pas réussi.
Bon ! Là, il va être beaucoup plus prudent,
il va même commencer à mettre des cameras,
cet espèce de psychopathe de merde
Alors, est ce qu'on ne peut pas passer par ailleurs  ?
Une porte derrière, peut être ? Une fenêtre ? Un truc ?
*essaye d'ouvrir une porte* nooooon ...
Attends, j'ai une idée : on va lancer la tomate dans le piège
D'accord
C'est bon, c'est passé !
Où est le marteau ? Il y a pas un marteau là ?
Il y a juste la lampe qui est là ... Put***,  c'est infernal.
Là, ce serait le moment d'aller choper la clé et d'ouvrir le cadenas
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaah !!
Et, quand tu t'y attends pas, mon pote, ça surprend !
Allez vite, on va choper la clé et on va ouvrir.
OUVRE ! OUVRE !
Pourquoi il ouvre pas ?
Ok c'est bon, ça c'est ouvert.
AAAAAAAAAAH
Mais non, mais non !
Oh ça me stresse trop !
OOOOOH What ?!
Alors j’espère juste qu'il n'a pas remis le cadenas ce con !
Il a remis le cadenas ? Non
Il faut trouver le marteau et le code et on est bon !
Put***, on va y arriver ...
Ok
Qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ?
Yes !!
C'est la lampe UV
Le code ! Le code ! Le code ! Le code ! Le code !
Non . Non
Put*** mais ou tu caches un code ?
Non ... Non
Oh 4785 4785
Ok Ok il nous manque juste le marteau le marteau
Non
Mais non... Cours chez toi , cours chez toi , cours chez toi bonhomme
Vas ch*** . Je m'endors
Ok c'est bon le lendemain voilà
Ça permet qu'il nous chope pas et qu'il renforce pas sa maison ça
Il faut qu'on trouve le marteau , il reste juste le marteau
4785 . Eh le code mec je m'en souviens mieux comme ma date de naissance
Le marteau il doit être dans le garage je pense c'est sûr
Allez pitié Yamakasi !
AAAAAAAAAH
Ça passe pas dans le sens
Le marteau !! Le marteau !! Le marteau !! Le marteau !! OOOOOH
Yes le marteau . Attends mec je m'en bat les cou****
Il arrive pas a nous trouver . On va foncer
Yes 4485
Mais attends c'est quoi NON ? 4785
OUVRE-TOI . OUIIII
Non
Mais non !!
Bah ça vallait le coup
Et voilà les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur "Hello Neighbor"
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu !
Ce jeu est genial !
C'est super bien que le mec s'adapte à ta manière de jouer
que à chaque fois que tu perds, il rajoute des pièges, etc ...
En plus c'est un voisin *rot* un poil gentil parce que à chaque fois qu'il te prend la main dans le sac,
Il t'assome, il te met dans ton lit  tranquillement ...
Et le lendemain, quand tu retournes, il a un petit peu renforcer la sécurité.
Il appelle pas la police, il te pète pas la gueule ...
Tranquille ! Et bien, on c'est bien fait troller ! Voilà !
Le jeu qui te troll le plus au monde ...
Merci "Hello Neighbour" ! Les developpeurs, je vous offre ce truc pour augmenter le decibel d'un micro
On a évidemment ce truc qui ne sert à rien !
Allez, à dans une prochaine vidéo, portez vous bien ! CIAO TOUT LE MONDE ...
Non.